Uh, there was another story
that I want to make sure
doesn't get forgotten.
Now, this one's about a judge
who was, let's say,
a bit too cavalier
in his sentencing.
REPORTER: 20-year-old
swimming star Brock Turner
could have been
looking at 14 years
for sexually assaulting
an intoxicated
and unconscious woman
behind a Dumpster
on Stanford's campus.
But instead of 14 years,
a judge has ruled Turner
will only spend
six months in jail,
eligible for parole
in three months.
Hold on a second.
It's 14 years or six months?
Those are the two options?
There's got to be
something in between,
like-like 13 years, maybe?
Or 13 years and six months?
(cheering, applause)
What am I missing?
God.
Or... or what the (bleep)
was wrong with 14 years?
How about that?
So, anyhow, the judge
said he understood
the devastation
the victim suffered.
Uh, but that
the "prison sentence would have
a severe impact" on Brock.
Yes, because if anyone
isn't supposed to change
after a brutal attack,
it's the attacker.
Brock, man, we're gonna
lock you up for a bit,
but promise you won't lose
that rapey side we love so much,
all right, man?
Don't change, man, don't change.
Now, in California,
the mandatory minimum
for this type of case
is two years,
and a judge can sentence
below that, but why would he?
REPORTER: The judge's reasoning?
The rape carried
"less moral culpability
because Turner was drunk
at the time of the attack."
That's a defense?
Was this judge drunk
at the time of sentencing?
(cheering, applause)
How...
Guys, think about this.
How does "too drunk" work
as an excuse for any crime?
Sorry I committed that DUI.
In my defense, I was drunk.
Get out of here.
Drunk should never be an excuse.
My coworkers still haven't
forgiven me for
the drunken crimes I committed
at staff karaoke night.
Right? Still paying for that.
Now, it could be that the judge
may have been swayed by a letter
from Brock 's daddy
in which he wrote...
"that is a steep price
to pay..."
I smell almonds.
Am I having a stroke?
"20 minutes of action?"
He describes rape as "action"?
Okay, I've said this before:
there's a reason why
we have words, okay?
And those two words
are not the same.
Only the most horrible
type of human scum
would say something
like that-- "action."
Not to mention, you would be
the worst movie director ever.
All right, everybody,
quiet on the set. Quiet.
And... rape.
Okay, that was bad.
That was horrible.
-I know, I know. True. Um...
-(cheering, applause)
Actually, uh, actually,
you'd be tied with
Roman Polanski
and Woody Allen. But...
That's right, I went there.
But... but action-dad
wasn't done.
"I was always excited
to buy him...
Who gives a (bleep)?
(cheering, applause)
God.
Who cares?
Oh... oh, the poor widdle fella.
Is the rapist
too raped out to eat steak?
Okay, here's what's
really gets me about this, guys.
It's 20-(bleep)-16,
and this is the best we can do
about sexual assault?
I... This is exhausting,
you guys.
Like, take this (bleep),
who I haven't
forgotten about, right?
(cheering, applause)
Right?
Okay, he's accused
of over 50 "actions,"
and we can barely get him
into a (bleep) courtroom.
REPORTER: We see
he's making his way there
through the metal detector.
You're not blind.
Open your goddamn eyes,
you fake-blind (bleep)!
You're not.
God.
But anyway, I just think
as a society, today,
I just think we have to find
a way to do better.